boom I'm entered I'm doing a tournament
crown stars for 7201 looking for three
players it's gonna be a tough one so far
judging by these guys 21:58 24 16 2162
23:36 one more player crown stars fisher
random chess waiting for one other
player and we have one other player okay
probably the most difficult pack of
players these are its free minute games
this is not a war zone six out of six
players are entered average rating is
2263 everybody plays each other then
koji round one okay gotta think fast my
opponents clock is ticking what's
unprotected nothing okay I think I want
to establish control in the center how
do I want to do that I think
I think this is a good start no I can't
put my finger on it as to why but okay
now I push forward in the center pomp
which pawn push here pawn push is the
queen gonna come out I don't think it
would be wise to do that but I'm gonna
try and get that in if I could get that
in I'd be really happy I have a center
now I want to support it or just advance
it okay now now what let's do this if
this pawn isn't a pin I want to break it
right away okay get my night out I don't
know which direction I want to castle
let me support that pawn get my other
night here I guess if they watch out for
the night getting here let's get my
other night out my dark square bishop I
could clean side Castle maybe queenside
castle is a good idea or maybe pawn push
a couple times let me try that okay kick
that bishop away and now he's a giant
thorn with dark square weaknesses maybe
my bishop wants to get on this diagonal
like my queen over here I think no I
can't even the night playing right here
is gonna be a pain that was a mistake
this Knight playing right here is gonna
be a giant pain let's see I control this
square
okay let's get that in there King side
castle and pawn push I'm gonna take with
my knight actually I have this square in
mind or this one if there's a pawn push
this Knight is probably how to play this
pawn my opponent better hang out of that
pond let's Castle kingside
and now what I'm just guarding this just
play fast maybe I should go here right
away
okay shitbox out this night maybe hmm
got the other rook I want to keep this
guarded probably get my queen somewhere
uh I don't want this file to open up
play here play here keep iooking a spot
where I could double Knight here I just
back up
I can't just take give a check I want to
kick that night away really soon
right now soon really tight game my
knight playing here is probably gonna be
very strong
maybe my opponent should take ok it's
not being taken Knight right here check
is gonna be tough to me I think really
difficult to meet this move pawn push
doesn't help Knight here is winning
stuff does the rook have to leave this D
file there's even Knight move here the
Queen could turn out to be trapped
I think rook here my just winning stuff
like check I think I'm winning stuff now
because I could grab on d1 with check I
could also grab on a 2 and my pawn on a
3 becomes passed so there might even be
instances where I could give this fish
up Bob oh I could get the rook now I was
just ready to take that but now this is
gonna be game over I'm hitting the
knight and the bishop the knight is in a
pin King here it's gonna be lights out
oh that move I didn't even consider that
okay um Queen trade Queen trade it's
actually working I think okay now just
grab this pond I believe it's a move I
could do no matter what and they say
pond is past tricky night let me just
stop the knight from being tricky first
rook there would have been more accurate
would have been winning stuff
why did I even allow that why did I even
allow that night to be there let's come
here push this pond away push him away
twenty my opponent has less time thought
it was me that was like that for a
second okay all right let me get this
pond next that Nighy
I just I want to get rid of him so bad
Kippy casting get behind this past pond
just keep pushing
stay behind that past pond no Forks no
Forks night takes like a pin and then
win and that's me
all right Wow good game man a game Ben
Koji let's see what's happening
elsewhere other games okay I didn't even
have time to look white 31 okay what's
unprotected this is it's the night
trying to go after that that's the only
thing that's unprotected think we're
gonna have both nights coming out here
pawn push right here I don't know if I
should be doing that right away I'm
gonna go with this actually this night
first because you know what I want to do
like a fee and kettle but then my knight
in the corner is kind of stupid
maybe I should establish a presence in
the center or not let's do this first
forget about kingside free and keto I
got to work on trying to get some grip
in the center my queen is stuck in the
corner just like my opponent's Queen I
don't know what side of the born I want
a castle on my opponent has a really
good center I think maybe getting my
pond my a pond rolling somehow just a
baby step it my LightSquared bishop my
bishop is probably just gonna have to
play here I have to be a little bit
cautious of f7 let's do this hon push do
I take first do I do this I have to
break it this okay wait no I know I do
this do I wait I wouldn't induce a pond
move I think my opponent to commit I
thought I was actually gonna be able to
win that it's castle and now I have an
idea my opponent castles b5 is my plan
okay let's go with the b5 open stuff up
for my queen and my rook pawn takes have
a take like that get my queen involved
some space for my queen let's back up
and now the the structure can close very
quickly and play might I let me let me
close that and hope on push might be
pretty good we're gonna see all right
hmm okay I have to back this guy up
all right let's back up pawn push could
still be very good we're gonna see
though I want to challenge this night
with my night maybe Nike seven and I got
to be very cautious of this square night
here pawn takes Knight takes Knight pawn
takes pawn not really working out he has
to go right now
and I come in this direction this pond
has hit three times it's only defended
what it's defended in no times okay if
I'm winning this pawn but I'm really on
my heels here
there might be some sacrifice on this
square could turn out to being a pin you
need to get out of the pin if if that
okay to do this support my Center and
let's ask that bishop a question I don't
have much time oh man I should be
thinking about posting up a knight right
here see what the bishop does first pawn
push here and then throw my knight on
this square then I'm dropping that it's
did this first pawn push knight here I
think would be good to be cautious of a
pin getting this Bishop on the corner to
corner diagonal we're about eve equal
with time before Knight c3
fortunately would come with tempo even
exactly on time now b4 Knight c3 I guess
rook c1 let's go up one step I want to
be able to take this Knight
if it plays here and I think that's what
the Knights intention is and I want my
Queen to be able to recapture I don't
want my knight to have to be the one
that recaptures on this square ok good
versus bad Bishop ending I guess is
close to happening ok I think no it's
not gonna happen like that I'm gonna
take there this is a really really nice
Center pomp which I feel like I'm
definitely the side that's doing better
let's shut down this [ __ ] up let's
protect this pawn and let's push here
next and then my bishop can actually
post up on c3 before I was talking about
a knight but also a bishop would be very
very good so I have a support point now
and now this rook is dead the Queen has
to play here
I don't want this pond to be a thorn my
queen is uh is well-placed here I have
two pieces covering that square time
situation to get this pond oh they could
have taken that that was bad what I just
did there past pond
the bishops gonna play here ha I was
just ready to get mated I was gonna take
with my queen that's gonna take with my
queen right there that would have been
bad I just want to stay connected watch
out watch out watch out watch out I'm
really gonna take oh man I got to defend
like this Oh No
seven seconds oh why does get so so
scary at the end clock situation oh I
got to weld I want to tell him oh man
back to tournament land ah I have won my
tournament game by default because my
opponent was not here okay so round
three apparently I have a bye
so when that happens what do you do you
go hunt somebody down you go hunt
somebody down okay so these guys are
going to be playing a game and I will be
watching wow did that get really intense
at the end I was having to defend that
battery why did I allow my opponent to
get so active I guess I should have just
taken that rook and then dealt with f6
or something okay here we go let's see
Ben Koji and this guy this is the guy
that I'm gonna have to play the one that
is playing the black side I have to play
against so
what is going on here Wow um black looks
to be doing pretty good because this
night has kicked away these bishops are
really good I like the space advantage
for black I like that this night could
be making use of this square maybe even
if it gives up upon this bishop then has
a direct shot down at b2 and we could be
seeing that okay now there's probing for
weaknesses how do you defend against the
weakness okay that's probably not the
way to go I would think because it opens
up this file and now this pawn is a weak
point
I thought Knight F night c1 would have
been best to defend and now I'm trying
to remove the defender 94 is very very
very strong move Knight takes is met
with Queen takes a and then Queen takes
Knight or even worse somehow so every
piece seems to be working now for black
and this Bishop is just kind of stuck
pawn takes is needed okay now there goes
a to less than two minutes for venko G
all right yeah let's see this finishes
up um can I always be a Queen trade that
would be my number one be considering
Queen c4 Queen c4 is not happening
Queen check where do you go just back
and forth actually King bee one that is
maybe Bishop a to check fought by Bishop
b3 and then the King is gonna be flushed
in this direction so we could be seeing
that right now [ __ ] of a - Bishop b3
with Queen a 2 to a 1
I guess the kinky kind of sit here for a
little bit you have to be a little bit
aware of I guess c5 potential exploiting
this pendants it's sure the Queen could
be taking but there's something there
seems like there's something - maybe
that c5 advanced a slight time advantage
actually for white who is down upon is
it worth it though who would you rather
be the one that is up
a little bit on the clock or team black
mmm ooh this guy logoff or something is
there a disconnect it might be a calm
casket no not the Comcast gambit Bishop
c4 God do rook takes rook first oh this
is gonna turn out to be trouble right
okay Oh bishop takes F rook takes rook
rook takes rook the rook would still be
hit okay now I guess trying to I guess
Benko sees this is maybe the best
resistance to not allow the King to get
kicked away here but this is gonna be
crumbling fast black is a very fast and
a very strong player simplification time
Queen d3 the Queen's are off and these
rooks are going to be getting very
active and we're gonna look here is most
accurate rook d1 after rook c1 is
actually being up a full rook however
you slice it if c1 up to d1 would have
been best okay we do have resignation
black now being up a full rook let's
close out of that and that and let's see
if there's still another game there is
another game this one right here 45
seconds each white is doing good white
is going to be winning against this guy
I would think about a 200 point edge
black has but you really can't get these
connected pass phones going can you
there goes the a pawn grab on B and push
the a pawn away or even sac the bishop
for the pun I might even be a way to go
about things
rook takes Bishop it was missed there in
super fast mode here the a pawn is very
fast they got that Bishop now the a pawn
is still very fast
okay oh this could get tricky let's see
rook beef rook here two pawns I'm the
sixth equate to a rook okay this rook is
there in time this pond is very fast
white only has 11 seconds the queen is
gonna be able to pick off one of these
ponds and there it goes
that's gonna be game over ten seconds is
a lot of time a lot of time queenie to
however you slice it
rook h one game over this one's over
white resigns or excuse me the player
white thirty-one resigns
okay that's finished waiting for round 4
pairings here we go I was just ready to
resign how's my opponent Noah that's a
good first move I better I better just
play a copycat game okay I'll do what
you do I'll do what you do that's the
plan okay now I guess I just support my
center okay let's support it like that
it's gonna be targeted I'll support it
again I guess I don't want to give that
up my bishop looks a bit stupid my
bishop looks a bit stupid here let's get
this pawn rolling my queen maybe gives a
check um let's get my night out it's my
night even doing my knight this square
there might be some sacrifice is there
queenside castle I guess I could be
running forward with Bishop here here I
don't know let's go here I don't know
what I want to do with this 9 or this
Bishop I'm looking for something a bit
sneaky right now and that is f5 ok let's
stop that pond from advancing f5 and
then get my knight into this square
somehow and if it's closed then I get
this advance in I'm able to play in the
wings very quickly I think things could
be ok if I get in f5
I'm able to get a night right there f-5e
five and then I get in this I'm gonna
try it so potential structural change or
it's a it definitely has to be a
structural change right now now I get
this advance in so I think I actually
stand better I think
okay pawn push pawn push here I'm gonna
go forward down keep going maybe even
further we're gonna see about that
maybe I want to stop right there my
LightSquared Bishop looks kind of
foolish maybe I'll Castle queenside my
knight wants to be where my bishop wants
to be in a different spot let's come
over here I think my knight wants to be
on that square or does he gotta go fast
I have to go fast my bishop wants to be
in a different spot let's come here if
pawn push then I jump into this square
he's and he's not so easily kicked away
okay I think I do that oh boy
actually I'm afraid now I'm gonna go in
there Pond takes I take like this this
is a connected past pond but if I take
with my night the night can make use of
this and then I have to worry about this
square I want to maintain this pond
right here and I need to break this pin
like a castle now like a Castle kingside
but maybe I want to close things up over
here first that's a good move
let's take tout and maybe I want to keep
my opponent guessing a little bit
I'm gonna keep my opponent guessing
Kings side or queen side where am I
gonna go I know where their king is okay
they I had to show my hand there and
Oliver good this is the direction we're
going in so there's still some tension
there's still potential for structural
change and now I want to get in what
this is where the next phase is going to
be taking place I don't know if I should
be doing too much too fast over here
my another Knight probably wants to get
here maybe I should have done that in my
other night right here Knight a six to
this square it's gonna be taken maybe I
take with my pun no I take like this I
still want this pawn break my white
square Bishop needs to be doing
something okay I think it's in a good
spot right here and now I could do this
pawn advance my queen needs to be in a
better spot where does my King want to
be less than a minute to figure this out
that's so easy
not so easy at all actually let's try
something else I need to reorganize
stuff I don't my queen
I want to exchange Queens I want to
exchange Queens not dropping that pond I
have enough on it right is that pawn
exchange gonna come about not just yet
my queen here my rook here and then my
king in a little bit better position
over here
I think cuz this is where the action is
gonna be maybe my bishop actually wants
to be here oh no oh no I forgot about
this
I'm in a giant knot over here I can't
get out of the knot
oh no I'm gonna giant knot um I goofed
I definitely goofed I can't I couldn't
even Tevan the Pont X was probably best
ah oh man I was not ready for that
transition I'm getting mated oh man
ah why didn't I see that takes good game
ah that was fantastic let's go back to
that that was really good
you see how offsides I was I committed
myself too much and they on this section
of the board on this area of the board
right here that tricky Knight just
sacked itself I thought soon you know
what I was fixated on I was fixated on
is all the kids I got another game let
me just complete that thought I was
fixated on my opponents light-square
bishop as soon as the LightScribe
bishops was off I thought okay I didn't
have to worry about any sacrifices but
I'm just forgetting about the 19 okay
oh well this is not too far off from an
actual prayer regular chess position so
maybe I start out with something that's
like in English because the King side is
very similar and Knight c3 Knight c3 as
a follow up g3 Bishop g2 so okay
g3 Bishop g2 okay yeah let's let's go
with this I need to move my ball it's
gonna take a while yet before I can
actually castle no actually I could
castle it inside after Bishop d2 Castle
queenside let's do this break the pin so
again very very similar to in English
all of a sudden out of that arrangement
so I guess the cool okay they've
committed themselves to
let's see give up the bishop or I'm able
to expand on the queenside with tempo
Bishop ty the one of these squares b4
okay I have the bishop here I guess pawn
push is the next thing to run forward
with mmm all right let's take care can I
get away with just taking on this square
hmm I don't want to Castle queenside I
don't think I might want to do this
actually as scary as it looks I might
want to do that this pawn is backwards
um cuz pawn push is gonna happen
definitely is gonna happen I think that
my opponent does really well oh wait oh
no the bishops gonna play to b3 uh okay
I mean I could defend but it's very
difficult to defend I gotta go in
reverse okay now I don't actually kick
this Bishop out of here I thought if
Queen here I'd have to play here okay
now Mike Castle at least the knight can
make use of this square but I want to
get back here as soon as possible I also
don't want to drop this pawn but it's
too late
yeah dropping the pot okay so you have
to mix things up now gotta mix things up
I'm down upon okay and now what now what
what do you do now do I kick that bishop
away I'm gonna take that the Knights
gonna play here okay there's tricky
stuff in this square but okay materials
balance this these guys are in a tough
spot though challenge this rook I guess
mm-hmm
Bishop here that no I gotta go I guess
here my bishop fortunately is gluing
stuff together I'm down to a minute Wow
okay I gotta kick this night away before
I can move my knight all right I guess
Knight here I got it he's he's gluing
everything together oh man a tricky Fork
ah why didn't I see a fork ah man King F
- I gotta go with this I need to keep my
tricky knight on the board without my
knight I'm dead why didn't I see that I
think I won't be able to hang on to my
tricky night can I take this maybe I'm
threatening to take it now maybe let's
see about this let's see is there any
resistance left
there's always resistance who is
doubting the tricky night I want to know
no don't take my tricky night you could
take this pawn though because now my
bishops constrained 36 seconds is not a
lot no it isn't nope no it isn't okay
hang on now hang on hang on to the
tricky night
hang on oh boy oh boy it's getting
dangerous actually it's been dangerous
but my knight is around fear that night
I'm also down on time Oh No can I get
this ten-second advantage ten-second
advantage oh it's a pasty pun
I don't have anything oh I got to get my
pond going somehow I'm dropping
everything though I'm dropping
everything dropping everything Oh No
there goes my tricky night and the game
run pond take that pond so I could hang
on to my tricky night ah take that pawn
I don't even know what that does
oh I shouldn't taking that bish up
doesn't matter though I'm gonna get
mated wedding I made it four seconds how
many time let him take my pond should
take my con why don't they take him icon
I can't move oh I just wanted to move I
lost that game too I couldn't move
ah
man I had that too I think if I would
have just moved I was trying to move my
king or my bishop or anything really
Oh third place confetti it seems like
it's so good but it's really not there's
only three players ah me I just wanted
to make a move my opponent was going
slow but guess who was going slower ah
man this comes out of that it's made in
that one down on time in that one games
you don't want to look back on good
games oh I really like that for that
first game I lost in the tournament that
sacrificed when I was so off balance
that was really really good I completely
forgot about that